Unsere heutige Welt ist schnelllebig und chaotisch
geprägt von Fortschritt, Technologie
und Kommunikation.
Uns beschäftigen Probleme.
Die alltäglichen
und die Internationalen.
Unsere Welt verändert sich heute jeden Tag immer
schneller.
Wir forschen mehr, wir kommunizieren mehr.
Es gibt heute mehr Menschen auf der
Welt,
als jemals zuvor in der Geschichte der Menschheit.
Du kennst diese Welt. Aber stell dir für einen Augenblick vor du verlässt diesen Planeten.
Stell dir vor du fällst heute ins Koma und öffnest
erst in 10 Jahren das nächste Mal die Augen.
Wie sieht die Welt aus? Was hat sich geändert?
Wie ist das Jahr 2026?
Wie stark hat sich der Alltag deiner Freunde
und deiner Familie geändert?
Wie sehen die Städte aus?
Welche Wendungen hat es in der
Politik gegeben?
Welche Probleme haben wir vielleicht gelöst?
Und welche Probleme sind in
10 Jahren aktuell?
Welchen Fortschritt hat die Technologie gemacht?
Die Frage, die dahinter steht ist: Siehst
du die jetzige Welt positiv oder negativ?
Wachsen uns Probleme wie Erderwärmung, Energieverbrauch,
Flüchtlingskrise oder Überbevölkerung über
den Kopf? Oder steuern wir getrieben durch
technischen Fortschritt auf ein goldenes Zeitalter
zu? Oder wird sich im Vergleich zu heute nicht
allzu viel verändert haben? Wir werden ein
paar Probleme gelöst haben und dafür sind
wieder ein paar neue aufgetaucht. Der Alltag
trottet vor sich hin, wie er es immer getan
hat. Nur dass das Smartphone etwas smarter
wird und sich unser Auto mit dem Toaster unterhalten
kann.
Als ich euch auf Facebook & Twitter gefragt
habe, wie ihr die Zukunft seht, habe ich ausschließlich
negative Zukunftsprognosen gelesen. Und das
bereitet mir Sorgen. Vielleicht noch mehr
als unsere temporären Probleme. Denn unsere
Einstellung dem Leben gegenüber bestimmt
auch unser Handeln. Was wird aus einer politikverdrossenen
Gesellschaft, die Angst vor der Zukunft hat?
Die Zukunft ist heute
undurchsichtiger als jemals zuvor. Es ist
schwierig sich etwas vorzustellen, das unseren
Alltag so sehr verändern wird wie das Internet.
Aber das nächste große Ding ist bis jetzt
immer gekommen. Eine Stromversorgung für
jeden Haushalt, ein Auto zum privaten Transport,
ein Telefon für die private Kommunikation.
Vielleicht ist es künstliche Intelligenz,
vielleicht ist es Virtual Reality. Vielleicht
ist es etwas, das noch nie jemand erdacht
hat. Niemand kann 10 Jahre in die Zukunft
sehen, aber deswegen ist es meiner Meinung
nach umso wichtiger einen positiven Ausblick
zu haben. Einmal zu träumen. Unsere Vorstellung der Zukunft beeinflusst auch
wie diese Zukunft wirklich aussehen wird.
Wir träumen vom Mars? Wir fliegen zum Mars.
Wie träumen von einer virtuellen Realität?
Wir bauen uns eine.
Also träumt. Wie sieht die Zukunft aus?